the New York Police Department is
working to show its softer side you
could say with some of its newest
cruisers Kris Van Cleave is in New York
Central Park with the efforts to improve
perception one ride at a time Kris good
morning good morning you know when they
talk about police cars these turn heads
when their lights and sirens are on but
let's show you one that's getting a
flood of attention and it doesn't even
have a siren it's a big reaction for
something that's anything but this isn't
the NYPD cruiser you are expecting but
the nation's biggest city is okay with
that
so is Officer Oh Donnie Acevedo you are
probably driving the world's smallest
patrol car yes the smallest good a ride
he uses to patrol New York's Central
Park where do you put the bad guy in
this thing
the smart car is intended for one
officer only so no bad guys in here it's
one of nearly 200 the NYPD uses mostly
for ticket riding and patrolling places
other cars can't like these narrow paths
in Central Park I don't with them
I've make them laugh I come come see the
card so I'm looking side it's not as bad
as you think I tell them and unlike the
three wheel scooter it's replacing the
smart car comes with air conditioning
and airbags it also costs about six
grand less when you went to the command
staff and said I want to add smart cars
what did they say they said no but
deputy commissioner Robert Martinez
didn't see wimpy at all he spent years
trying to get this recruit into uniform
I would call it friendly I've caught
neighborhood friendly it's disarming
it's kissable and huggable the cuddly
Cruiser is proving to be a hit the
public can't seem to get enough good
from small and mighty to the world's
cutest police car even you're kidding
right but no joke all these pictures are
generating big-time social media buzz
sure the horses may be bigger but which
is smarter they told cute nice right
what do you think ala cool right the
kind of cool that makes a park full of
strangers approach a police car and the
officers like their old friends you're
the center of attention out here what's
that like you've got kids coming up and
parents people taking pictures yeah it
feels good you know a lot of people come
up to me ask for pictures and it's
always a good feeling now this police
car does not respond to emergency calls
and they're not supposed to exceed forty
miles an hour in the car so it's not
going to replace the bigger police
cruisers but it is proving that you can
get pretty big things out of one very
small car gale well I'm glad the big
cruisers will still be around - thank
you very much Chris Van Cleve